jean-noël barrot sera candidat à
l'élection législative partielle du 1er
et 9 octobre prochain l'actuel ministre
délégué à la transition numérique et aux
télécommunications se présente à sa
propre succession
un scrutin organisé dans la 2e
circonscription des yvelines suite à la
démission de sa suppléante anne crignon
anne crignon qui était ma démarche
suppléante il y a cinq ans avait figuré
avait pu figurer sur une liste aux
élections sénatoriales de 2017 de fin
2017 n'ayant pas été élus elle était
restée ma suppléante pendant cinq ans
mais ne pouvait pas être ma suppléante
aux élections législatives de juin 2022
bien que notre candidature et ait été
validé au moment où elle a été déposée
effectivement l'article l eau 134 du
code électoral dispose un député un
sénateur ou le remplaçant d'un membre
d'une assemblée parlementaire ne peut
être remplaçant un candidat à
l'assemblée nationale nommé ministre le
4 juillet dernier le député de la 2e
circonscription des yvelines a cédé son
siège à sa suppléante si nous devons
revoter c'est parce qu'un recours a été
formé contre l'élection de juin par un
candidat qui a été battu dès le premier
tour et qui veut rejouer le match en
s'appuyant sur une contradiction du code
électoral qui est largement méconnue
pour l'élection législative partielle
jean-noël barrot se lance avec une
nouvelle suppléante anne bergholtz élu
local à lévis un nom elle pourrait
devenir la future députée de la deuxième
circonscription
pour rappel au second tour de l'élection
législative de juin dernier jean noël
barrot député sortant l'avait emporté
avec 64% des suffrages